i think it just sucks for everybody and
it like sisters can get over it i don't
know if
you know if you're not a sister how easy
that is to get over it
kendall and kylie jenner may have had a
super epic fight
i came back at her smacked her in the
face and then she took her heel
and put it into my neck why i started
kicking her back
no we got in a full fight but don't
expect their big sisters
courtney kim or khloe kardashian to pick
a side this family we
feel like it's a revolving door just a
little refresher
the sisters got into a nasty argument
during a family trip to palm springs
it all started when kylie swiped the
outfit kendall planned to wear
for their night out oh like you deserve
the outfit more
it was for me i'm having a good time
but ish really hit the fan later when
the supermodel ended up in the same car
as kris jenner's boyfriend corey gamble
and kylie
at the end of the night
things got physical after kylie refused
to have the driver drop
kendall off at her house which was
apparently out of the way
and kendall accused corey of dropping
one choice
four-letter word corey on everything
said
you and like turns around to the front
of the do not answer
and no i'm not and i said you hear what
i said you and that's when i started
getting hysterical i'm dead sober i
wouldn't make
[ __ ] up and she's smashing me she
smacked me or something and so i
came back at her smacked her in the face
and then she took her heel
and put it into my neck why i started
kicking her back
no we got in a full fight the fact that
my sister
my blood was reacting that way
it's so upsetting flash forward and kim
kor and chloe are doing what sisters do
best dishing on the drama there was
already tension when the night started
there was tension at dinner she didn't
come to the drag show
but it was building up and building up
and i think it just boiled over and
that's what happened
yeah and since they weren't in the same
car they aren't exactly sure what went
down
but kim says kendall wouldn't have
reacted that way for no reason
they had a sister fight cory happened to
be there he's now in the middle of it
it's just super annoying coco also
points out that while kendall was sober
kylie and corey had been drinking i just
don't think they were being logical
and kendall has this anxiety that she
really struggles with
just even like her shaking and her being
so upset
is that when she's in the car i don't
think she's had that kind of adrenaline
since she's been an adult
i just feel bad that mom's in the middle
i really do like i couldn't imagine
feeling like that
it just sucks and the good american
designer admits she knows a thing or two
about getting in a fight with a sister
i've had my fair share of sister fights
and it turns into a whole
slew of emotions so i just want kendall
to feel supported
but picking a side is not going to do
anything right now so i just helped
kennel and kylie figure it out
yeah you might remember it was chloe who
had to intervene when kim and court
threw punches earlier this year
stop okay stop you too okay is it just
me
or is keeping up with the kardashians
giving you major jerry springer vibes
lately
anyway those fights won't be seen on tv
much longer
in september the karjenners announced
that after 20 seasons and 15 years
their hit reality show is coming to an
end in talking to
the family this was a very very hard
decision for them to make
when eti caught up with the show's
executive producer ryan seacrest
he told et the decision to walk away has
been a tough one
you know before and after the
announcement came out they were
emotional we were trading texts and
emails after the announcement
uh and you look back at 14 years and 20
seasons of a camera
in your life and think about that at
some point you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it
you